jours vous allez bien oui avoue on n'est
pas payé merci depuis un an chloé est
accompagné par la mission locale rurale
de bonnes tout juste majeur la jeune
femme a besoin d'être épaulée pour
s'insérer dans la vie sociale et
professionnelle
par exemple pour pour l'emploi je ne
savais pas où trônent tournée d'encore
et puis c'est vrai qu'on va mal et il
sont puis le logement si pour trouver un
logement tout seul 7 j arriverai pas et
puis bon c'est vrai que j'ai pas non
plus les parents qui sont derrière moi
donc à voile elle peut compter sur
l'aide de sandrine conseillère ici
depuis 17 ans notre particularité c'est
d'accompagner le jeune sur tous les
types les thématiques qui le concerne
donc non seulement l'emploi ou l'accès à
la formation mais aussi le logement la
santé les aides financières s'il ya
besoin la mobilité le permis comme chloé
plus de vingt mille jeunes ont été
accompagnés par la structure depuis son
ouverture en 91 tout rien fait partie
des tous premiers bénéficiaires suivi
pendant sept ans au milieu et la pj et
c'est isabelle parfait at war et 6 et
delvin aujourd'hui aide à domicile elle
est parfaitement inséré donc je vais
continuer mes études j'étais inquiet
peut perdre et puis voilà grâce à
isabelle j'ai fait beaucoup de choses je
vais les allées loin mais bon là surtout
grâce à toi
pour cette conseillère salariés des
premiers jours les différentes
générations faut constamment évoluer sa
mission
ce n'est plus du tout les mêmes jeunes
qui avaient il ya 30 ans là on est dans
le plein emploi les gens ont besoin des
jeunes ont besoin de deux choses assez
rapidement tout et tout de suite et nous
voilà ils sont dans la demande nous on
est là pour les aider à coop les
accompagner au mieux la mission locale
aussi agrandi passant au fil des années
de trois conseillers avant salariés
aujourd'hui